o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o lugar
que seja muito bem vindo já é mais um
vídeo e hoje na chique que o jr o que eu
tenho a dizer sobre isto muita coisa
indignado mas facilmente ter um ep
usinas em 3d é de uma lua subir e está
na versão zero ponto 3.2 o que quer
dizer que isto é fabuloso cleantes 15 e
eis o catar por criar jogos dentro dum
jogo xuxa land tributo leão da ilha
desde limita sol só sr elétrica sobre
che e deixe de experimentar onde estamos
então escalar experimentar dia no pa só
precisa assim mais feliz né
olha só o chinês dentro do carro ganda
carro muito gostoso sileti workwell
jovem jimmy baralho não conhecer super
herói do chelsea um filme no cinema vai
mostrar o xetra já se viu não foi a
corte já anunciado pela prefeitura que
13 mil deles são ricos o colar e pelos
3d da fox não funciona assim
bicicleta pessoal então filhos registrar
desta viagem para o gol meu deus só tomo
nada panorâmico
eu acho que é melhor começar isso né a
ohl já sem dar já sei e nas teclas i de
pinheiros bairro de maranello mas pelo
que me disseram espera por si com um ep
uso porque não avançando porque com a
queda de e filho não te preocupes filho
ao meu filho o carro mantém o espírito
inscrito não sei pra onde fugir e está a
fugir fim piada que há muito boa é que
meu braço entrou dentro da clavícula gay
é assim que está de bicicleta assim
disponível e que ainda no veículo o
[ __ ] ainda agora que você já caiu
o que não pode é o meu filho
agora já sei andar de bicicleta do filho
não te preocupes o pai para kaká pegou o
[ __ ] quilômetros leva sangue assim a
bicicleta está sendo gravado este jogo é
muito sinistro o filho agora o perímetro
de buscas cinco avançados assim o
esta é a minha cara oficial é sempre
esse pessoal que eu gosto muito
agora estamos no mapa o filme sai aimar
é nova dança dança de bicicleta o que
será esta chegada de braço com acerto
preocupe filho vários bairros também
espancar alho e os braços segundo exibe
50 31 metros meu deus calma filho isto
vai passar não continha manhã à chegada
e embaralhou uma vez como um dom que
leva o dono tem fãs dessa aparelhagem de
som isso é bom já possui em seu passado
na estrada o botafoto em nani cantar a
música do senhor meu deus cadê quando é
que quando criança sempre esta máquina
que manda zé rodolpho que ninguém acerta
no que aconteceu fica aqui ó paí ó que
realmente meu filho calculávamos rocha
agora vai agora vai muito fácil muito
fácil assim o deus sol muitos que valor
das terras olha só nunca digo ó apoio
uma certa
nené mas o contorno maio parece um bife
rodas chão cortou a perna como assim em
canelinha agora comecei a andar só com
uma perna eu sozinho só se dão em 50 não
expulsar aquela que é isto vai fazer o
bolo deus sou muito radical e eu sou
muito sul muita aventura do ouro ventura
aero ching gasto passa muito bem na liga
lá e gugu conseguir pegar um documento é
harley teste em campo limpo
o pessoal chega tiverem dizem agora
vamos para um velho a 3 mesmo curto o
caraças tem rampa em cima do monte fuji
vamos lá por baixo e vinhos
talvez eles tenham conseguido fugir
muito bonito aí o teu e trazendo o gosto
do cara tá muito cheio de música épica
música épica anos produção foi uma
música épica mil porque cara de que
agora esse inferno muito gostoso agora
vai agora vai para isso nunca sequer de
fundo já sabe produção meta música é
agora deus 80 quilômetros por hora o
nintendo lutou na guerra
meu filho não financia olha foram às
ruas em bora bora bora bora eu posso
encaixar tá bom filho e isso eu não pra
isso nem é isso tão suja na bicicleta
luta
victory qual é muita serra ayew inkoom
há muito está montado baseado alto pra
mim que estou sustar a gestão do turismo
responde assim olha agora são 54 x
melhora vai agora vai agora podem
confiar em mim agora vai ficar sem
camisa do eu aqui nas minhas partes mas
sim é igor votou o isto fez com bo a
serra cortou um pedaço de carne caiu em
cima da minha e não explodiu e um prazo
caso ainda bateu na série por josé rico
tocada
vamos tentar fazer button por fora a
impossível é possível também que estas
minas [ __ ] aí é o [ __ ] coxa ai ai
não culpa o quadro não é composto por 33
4 por 57 a 55 [ __ ] no cursinho
gostoso
ae
roupas e em 34 segundos rapaz que vocês
não conseguem [ __ ] vamos jogar só
mais um mapa salário o flu merdas meu
deus cuidado com o fumo levá la por seu
nome isso a ficar agitado muito como é
que os querem que o país é do site the
guardian
só me escondendo um bicicleta o número
lua dólares filme lembra a luta por um
pirata usou um canhão com assim e onde é
que eu joguei muito fácil ainda mais
cara é muito difícil entrar o que o rei
não pode me ei eu passei a serra no
domínio e tinha uma certa faixa de
pronta-entrega que entoou chão cuidado
vocês vão me ligar na bahia essa minha
há muita calma nessa hora da taxa de 50
cuida aí muitos recrutas ias costa quase
isso está tudo cheio domina é possível
passar aqui sem dúvida é algo muito
difícil conseguir do porto do douro é o
homem caldo na única ou vaca sagrada do
pessoal vamos ficar porque com isso
espero que vocês tenham gostado
destruindo glory já sabem quanto como o
site favorito como tenho que fazer
chorar não escrever mais fiquem bem até
a próxima semana